hello hi it's very late I am very tired
and I probably look like it so I just
wanted to make a video to tell you guys
that I just got done with the
make-a-wish Foundation award ceremony
they do this every year and this year I
was given the make-a-wish Foundation
celebrity of the Year award and that's
just incredible I have no idea why I
wanted I really don't understand what I
did to deserve it I I'm still trying to
process all the emotions that I just
went through I I didn't even have like a
speech prepared when I when I got up
there and I had both at once and it was
horrible for me because I I just I I was
ill-prepared and then before they showed
these clips of all the kids that I've
met and all the kids that like I have
somehow helped and and like of the like
people that somehow my videos have
touched the lives of and I was I was
distraught to say the least I'm better
now I'm in a better place now
I'm not weeping openly but right before
I was supposed to go onstage it was just
my god it was a waterfall of Tears I was
growing like a little baby the boat side
people were patting me on the shoulder
and be like congratulations and I turned
going thank you so much Lily oh oh jeez
you're right it was obviously not and
then I had to get up on stage and I had
to wing an entire speech for an award
that I didn't think I deserved like
honestly do I deserve this I've only
been doing this for a year and there
were there were two other winners of
this award it's not just I'm not the
celebrity of the year there's two others
one was the entire team of the Dallas
Cowboys and then one was Tom Kenny the
voice of Spongebob and various other
cartoons and all sorts of other stuff
he's done voice acting for like 300
different things so well deserved on
their part but I only started doing this
like a year ago and and the first the
first make-a-wish thing that I ever did
you guys know Patrick who is also known
as shot leech and I've done some videos
with him he's got a YouTube channel and
he was a great kid and and I still
consider him to be one of my friends
today and you know the second kid I met
was a girl by the name of Danelle and
I'm sure some of you guys know Danelle
because I did a video when I went out to
Houston to meet Danelle and Danelle
passed away a couple months back when I
first heard about that news it broke
inside it was devastating because I
honestly
I hadn't
I hadn't caught up you know I hadn't
kept up with her and like I felt like I
didn't do enough there I felt like I
didn't I felt like I didn't do enough to
help her and so when I got I'm sorry I'm
getting sidetracked when I got when I
got on stage I was a mess
and I was distraught and I was trying to
come up with a coherent line of thought
and everyone tells me that I did okay
but honestly I don't remember a word
that I said other than that I feel like
I need to work harder to earn this award
I feel like I need to do so much more to
earn the title of celebrity of the year
for the make-a-wish Foundation I've
apparently made 13 wishes and the most
amazing thing is to see the effect that
this has on the kids and the families
the families are so grateful I just put
myself at me like what are we doing this
oh man but it's just like I feel like I
could do so much more and I feel like
I'm getting back on the right track I
really do I feel like I wasn't doing
enough with the charity livestreams and
I wasn't doing enough with the charity
efforts in general and now that I have
this studio space I have Tyler helping
me we've got another charity livestream
scheduled for November 19th be there and
then the next one we're going to do in
December and we're going to do them
every month without fail and I just feel
like I have to do more I I'm pretty sure
my speech went along the lines of I will
commit the rest of my life to make sure
that I deserve this award because I
haven't done enough and everyone was
like congratulating me and saying
telling me thank you for all that I've
done and I legitimately don't feel like
I've done it
and them done enough to these kids I
haven't enough for the families I
haven't done enough for you guys like
because these kids don't just represent
these kids these kids are all of you
like there's so many other families that
are suffering and there's so many and
god these these kids have to go through
these horrible like horrible diseases
I wish and they should have to
ah they shouldn't have to but they're so
strong for it and they are just the most
incredible people you could ever meet
how gracious they are oh um it's been an
emotional day and I'm in a better place
now and I needed to get this stuff out
of my head and that's why this weird
weight late-night upload I didn't even
mention this I haven't done a hotel
phone vlog in ages so sorry about the
[ __ ] quality there's no lights here and
it's dirty but where was I have annoyed
but just thank you guys and I'm sorry
for not being the best that I can be and
the best that I should be but I will in
the future because this this means this
is the most meaningful thing I've ever
gotten in my life this is the greatest
thing that I've ever received I can't
describe in words how honored I am to
have it how humbled I am to have it how
much it means to me that like this is
real and the effect that my videos have
on people is real I've said it before
but this just solidifies it in a way
that I've never seen before and again I
know it's a late night weird upload and
also I don't even know if I'm going to
be able to give videos out tomorrow I
have a late night or early morning
flight back to LA and then slowly I'm so
tired but I don't even think I can get
any sleep but when I get back to LA I'm
going to try my best to edit videos and
getting them up later in the evening if
I can't I'm sorry but make no mistake I
am
100% committed to being there for you
guys and thank you guys so much for
being there for me I wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for you guys I wouldn't have
these opportunities to help people if it
wasn't for you guys and like you're part
of all of this you're part of everything
that we here do is community and I just
want to say thank you for being there
for me and thank you for believing in me
so that I could start believing in
myself and believing that I can earn
this award so anyway I think I've
rambled enough like again just like my
speech on stage I have no idea if I set
a coherent string of thoughts but I got
it out of my head and just thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to a lot more community related
charity related helping people related
stuff in the future so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]